c'est tout simplement ce qu'il vaut
mieux éviter de faire rester bloqué sur
ce marquage au sol
sécurité oblige vous savez quand vous ne
pouvez pas être au milieu là je ne
savais pas je suis pressé dans ce moment
depuis la mise en circulation des bus à
haut niveau de service le doute s'est
installé chez un certain nombre
d'automobilistes en fait quand vous êtes
là bas je me rattache jeu non je
m'arrête au stop c'est pas moi quand ya
pas de jeu ralentit un feu clignotant
quand le bus arrive qu'ils s'arrêtent
après son passage plus le marquage au
sol
que faire le pavé mosaïque a pour but
d'attirer l'attention du conducteur sur
l'endroit à l'endroit donc même si le
feu ne fonctionne pas en faveur de
l'automobiliste c'est de l'autre côté là
bas est bouché il ne doit pas s'arrêter
sur le pavé mosaïque parce que s'ils
s'arrêtent dessus et puis ça dure la
bouteille à jour très longtemps de
l'autre côté et en même temps ils
arrivent en bus il y aura problème selon
ce moniteur auto école
ce feu n'aurait pas sa place en
martinique ça fait parler d'effets
spéciaux qui se trouvent pour les traits
aux barrières de passage à niveau pour
les avions audrey peut-être laissé comme
il est là pour ne pas faire de frais
et puis m rouge on s'arrête vers un
repas terminé
alors sur la route à sainte thérèse
carrefour dillon au lamentin vigilance
sécurité et civilité sont plus que
jamais d'actualité
fais attention aux motos et puis à
certaines voitures les taxis tout ça qui
utilisent la voir c'est votre premier
cours tout à fait c'est un peu stressant
pour moi mais
faudra que je sois un peu très vigilante
et aussi faire attention qui me tient à
doigts titre il ya le respect de la
signalisation parlent tous les usages et
les taxes qui les automobilistes les
piétons 10 ans et une éducation routière
et de voiliers à voir dans cette
situation il faudra donc un temps
d'adaptation avant de s'habituer au
passage de ces bus à haut niveau de
service